As you probably noticed I'm not Craig. My name is Lily Gladstone and for the next 15 weeks,
I'll be leading you through Crash Course Film Production. First a little about me. I'm an actor and I love movies.
I love making them, watching them, thinking about them, in fact
I've spent most of my adult life acting in or educating people about movies and all of that has brought me here, to Crash Course
Filmmakers do great things and some not great things with cameras, lights microphones,
actors, makeup, costumes and special effects. They put together all these puzzle pieces to perform an amazing trick and communicate ideas
and emotions on a two-dimensional screen.
They make us laugh, cry, squeal, cover our eye and every movie starts very simply: starts with an idea.
Maybe it's a grand vision of an intergalactic war or a small and tender tale about a woman trekking across
country with her dog. Either way both these ideas go through many transformations before they arrive in a movie theater on Netflix or on Blu-Ray.
But how?
How do you take an idea and turn it into something that you can show people and how do you get people interested in helping
you make it? How do you cast it, crew it, edit it, for it and release it?
Are you going to direct it and what does the director
actually do? What are producers anyway? Do you even need one? Actually let's get this one out of the way right now.
Yes!
Producers are very necessary and like
how much does this all gonna cost? Do you need two hundred million dollars to bring your idea to life
or do you need two thousand? With this series
we hope to demystify a lot of these questions
and help everyone understand just how much goes into making a movie. Because working on films is fun and exciting!!!
But it's also a lot of very focused work that can turn into chaos if you're not prepared or paying attention. So join me,
Lily Gladstone, for the next 15 episodes of Crash Course Film Production produced in association with our friends at PBS digital studios.
[Theme Music]